How do you suggest nebulizing colloidal silver and the frequency?
You can nebulize just about anything that can be dissolved in a liquid.
What are the best things to nebulize for the lungs? Well, there's the hydrogen peroxide and you
do that based upon the recipe that's on the member's home site, home page. So the recipe for
nebulizing hydrogen peroxide is a downloadable PDF of the member's home page. So that's good
for a person's lungs. That would be good for an infection of the lungs. That would be good for
lung cancer. That's what would be good for the lungs. Colloidal silver. Can you nebulize colloidal
silver? Yes, you can't. You would put that directly. You don't water the colloidal silver. Now you
put that directly in the nebulizer. How often could you do it? Well, you could do it daily.
You could alternate to the colloidal silver and the hydrogen peroxide. There's different things that
you could mix. You could kind of mix up with that. But so there is no trade-in through. You can only
do it so many times and things like that. Colloidal silver, you can get too much colloidal silver.
But you know, you have to be doing it 10 times a day probably to get too much colloidal silver.